I don't want to be Prime Minister he got  term in David Cameron a brilliant Prime  Minister having Seaton close up how he  does the job I know that I couldn't do  if anyone wants to get me to to sign a  piece of parchment in my own blood  saying that I don't want to be Prime  Minister if that's what it takes then  I'm personally having to do that  are you considering the leadership there  oh there we go there's the leadership  I'm a steel I can tell you I'm  absolutely not  the one thing I can tell you is that  there are lots of talented people who  could be Prime Minister after David  Cameron but cut me out  I have concluded that person cannot be  you